This is our heart and here our streets are Tory.
Project Park Library in February two thousand and
three and I'm
hearing where you are or have was born in Berkeley.
If
you work in Bedford Stuyvesant in nineteen
thirty nine.
No
no I was there until I was swimming lessons. Then my family
moved to
Queens. So I feel my parents had a candy store on the
corner of Stuyvesant in green and then it was a
very hard life going to my father kept the store open fiction a
half day and he opened it at seven in the morning and
close to that eleven and he take a nap in
the afternoon. So when they were able
to say they shoulda it and move
to clean and.
You know send the candy
store was my parent's
way. Of. In a sense getting them self
out of the depression during the depression my father.
Had been snatched he was his trade he was a had happened trend
maker and he had a care and
I hatched a war on change Mark seven you and
that business sale and. It was very hard for him to find
work after that
as I don't know how many years. He was found and who or what had
just occasional work but my parents had
to go and live with his mother who had
a brownstone on Vernon they have a new.
What you have yes.
I was born on.
Six months and after my
parents bought the
store when they bought the store my parents my mother was pregnant with me.
I have a brother who was born in that same location
in nineteen forty five and I have an older
sister and to tell you the truth I don't know where my
parents lived when she was born but she's nine years old at night.
So I knew her very young.
Oh now I remember many memories who have a store. I
mean. Why didn't we had
all fashioned penny candies where with
us why entered Kalash showcase.
And you know kids would look in one of those along
of and we also have a very small
fountain was cerise two walls and my
father made malted she made the best small thirds when he
made Sundays.
And I actually of the chic read of the exceptional malted but I will tell
what are you made a cream.
Of
course and we have I think three or four.
Besides For found which had a marble.
I don't know what you call him
character. We also had three or
four square tables
with
wire chairs all fashion. Her chair she
was wooden feet
and. We also have
I counter that where she grew
Red Shea and
cigars were sold. And
we had magazines and the comic
books
were in a commoner. And I used to
love to sit there and read the comic books on the days they came in
I'd read a hundred.
I used to
during I mean I remember the store during the Second World War
became irradiate an eerie drill
saying everything would go
door and Air Raid Wardens was come around they were the only people
who had a little flashlight going
on the
floor
and in a storage shed we
sold cigarettes and cigars and
tobacco pipe
tobacco and I too remember shelling
single cigarettes which will call whoosh.
And at that time they were penny
apiece. You can say wow riled.
That's my sister's job she was. I
said nine years older than I was.
Was to make
up the newspapers especially putting together
the section of
the Sunday I didn't have a job I guess to use
to do it. But that was her responsibility to make up
the Sunday papers and put all the sections together.
I we had some really wooden phone booth.
Whoa whoa.
And. For those phone booths
we get holes for people in the neighborhood.
And one of us would go out and ring their bell and tell them they had
a phone call.
Would go to work
remember we had a stand with newspapers outside
the door not unusual in those days we had also.
Why
one of use
nettle ice chests. Where
there were things like ice cream pie
can get clique up. You've heard of those now
or roles.
Or maybe the men were worlds winners. There may be three. Father kept them at
the the soda
fountain.
But again how it was lively It was a neighborhood
play for a never but I knew what it was.
Not like. People whose parents went to work someplace
away and. The
neighborhood
was majority African-American. And.
And
see. You know white
kids were you think your way Shaw
capital. And the Catholic
being Irish or Italian background.
Now when I was in the third grade. I remember the
first. Puerto Rican cheered to come into
my class and that was
probably. Nine hundred forty eight or forty nine mine
and I remember this. So
clearly his name was Jose.
And but I saw he spelt it with a J.
And that was inconceivable to me
because it was an H.
sound. And he was a funny kid a
mish G.U.V.'s kid. I was a goody goody.
Set. I was quite a dog
walker and
walking for my house we live behind the
store. That's another important thing. So my parents were never
away for a bit really
and
walking to school.
I wish. Jeff the door to where I had to walk
one
block. And the other
block I
think I'm not sure what it was to get to my school P.S.
fifty
seven.
And I
remember I would just always thought of the old be
like how you call it the
hatches or for the farewell great tonight run up and down.
And I'd be walking up appliance or growing in the.
In the cracks in the
sidewalk and I was invariably late for school
so
I left in plenty of time my
mother saw
that.
What else can I tell you remembering that there was a butcher
across the
street in Nice. Blocks And still to this
day
the stores were on the corners. And the butcher curse
the
street was Polish and you
know I remembers name Polish can have
one and I don't give a given was
there and my mother was
from Bialystok but that was from
a Jewish section of Poland and say she grow up speaking
Yiddish she learned a little bit of
polish in.
When she went to
school and she was so proud of herself when she could
remember especially the Polish were to tell her this but you.
And on the other end of our street. He was a
grocer and they
were Jewish it was the
Lieberman and you know they
were good
friends with us and we were friends with
the people who lived in the building
more. Especially my
sister. I mean we didn't have very much
room behind the
store. There was kind
of two rooms a kitchen in the bathroom and so
as my sister got older. Remember
we were live there or Intel she
was perhaps in her junior
year college or pro con college.
That
she we rented a
room for her upstate. Shares in the apartment of one of
our
neighbors because it just wasn't enough room.
When she was older and she just quiet to study and
that's
stuff.
I'll tell you also
about the candy store and moving to Queens.
My mother a wish for the school. Why even an
accomplishment that they were able to do that because
they had those
years of
just being depended on my
grandmother who you know I don't know where she
had any money from she when she came to this country she was a
widow and she married a man with six
children. All right well it wasn't so weird then.
And
and so she had the house she inherited the house when
he died. That's how she got
a brown stuff
from her husband Mr Black who was always called
Mr Glass.
He was never called anything else.
And my father was close with children of
his
sadness and one of
them worked for us in the store he would do his out there
job in the morning which is tell the truth I don't know what it was and
then he come in the
afternoon and work in the candy store. Till dinner
time while my father
no less I said my father open and close
the
store.
What else can we tell you about this. My mother
said You should we make such
a killing after the war when you've
got marble girl three years he had been you know Bob
although I don't know why.
But I'm They did get this. I
guess bazooka or something like
that and you're SOL white black hot cake and
that was exciting to her.
We
didn't have a car during the war when my parents had a core when they
were young married but also when the
beginning gas gas gas was ration and oh who had ration books.
Of
course. And I had a whole
bank account when you bring in Nic also quarters and put it in your
bank account every week.
We
use to collect
the fat from cooking. And take
it I don't know where we took that puppy to the butcher and they
would use it I guess in some kind of whale a few
all
our immigration books. Well know.
You can see from the pictures that of course my brother had
a high carriage and I remember
going to there was the first war
Bones' supermarket was on decal Bhavin you use a
good
walk from us near the Bushwick why
bery you know that it's not cold.
Question why there is a time Bush or Andy
Kalb maybe called it a caravan.
We use to walk there and shoot buy groceries and we put them in the
carriage with my brother and take them back.
Once
in I remember Brown growing up member.
There With You should
real Brooklyn gay parades and the
Brooklyn Day parade
with the wish to call it anniversary day because it was the
anniversary of the public
school. My now public school
I guess
the Christian
school. That union founding.
And it was mostly kids and
baby carriages that would get courageous with
flowers that we made from folded
tissue and never was a day we had off from school and they
had they still as a Brooklyn Queens
Day and it all it was a Brooklyn Sunday School
new minyan that's what it was call.
And I
remember our feet
both VE Day and V.J.
Day.
And now I don't just standing. If the war was over how come it will hold
for
again
and till it was
explained to me and I remember people are dancing young star Iverson have a
new Everybody been loud and
throwing. You know turn our paper is considered
a if it's a kind of thing you know
I
remember the day Franken knows who more than
I would have my
grandmothers and I turn the radio. Oh
I used to listen just soaks up my lunch hour from
school. I used to listen to and they were fifteen minute show
barbers I get all Friday and and G.N.A.T.
those are the true I used to listen to and I was
at my grandmother's house that day and I went to put on the
radio and all I could get was
classical
music and I didn't understand
it and then it was explained should
be and and I remember I don't know what day of the week now.
Was that all the programs were changed in
respect
for President Roosevelt
there.
And. Let me see something
else
about that I remember the cover of The Daily
News magazine section was an
uncompleted portrait of him. That was
being painted at the time that he died.
And I was on the cover that
I also remember the
election for Truman and doing.
And a question our family.
Everybody loved Roosevelt. But my father always said he
loved Roosevelt and he voted for him but he was a
Republican and of course effort all the other. Adults.
MY DAD Yes my sister my mother. They voted Democratic and my
father voted
do
and you know it needs
like no real friction but some in the
family and then when doing what do we did not when after
the newspapers predicted he would win it was
an event.
Where
else to our member I remember so many saying
I know Queen should you make a high school.
I in fact
I we moved after I finished the
fifth grade.
P.S. fifty seven.
So I had sixth grade and then junior high
school including.
Right well I went to Jamaica High
School. And then I went to Queens College was a chemistry
major and I couldn't imagine what I would do was tamest but I
did I never really thought about having a career.
I was just good at school and I continued to do what I was good
at that's what. And so I went to graduate school
I think well like I can't imagine what I could possibly do chemistry.
So I decided I don't fly for
biochemistry in graduate school.
And I actually went to Harvard.
And I ended up in microbiology.
And I like I mean. But I was
never meant to be rushed or I didn't have enough confidence that
I was
doing so I was really mostly a
teacher.
When we came we live in
Manhattan. My husband.
When our daughter
was born and for your better.
One bedroom apartment get a bigger place we looked all around.
We never knew he grew up in the Bronx.
But we never knew about Portugal. It was not
an area we ever
knew you know we
had family or I did who
live on cram
high tide and showed I
had cousins on my father's side who lived on
Carroll story but it was Carol. All the way damn probably
near downstate something I didn't know this neighborhood
as. Well.
Although my
grandmother lived on Vernon venue and
my husband who is from the Bronx. His
grandmother no longer alive for nine matches had
been lived on Hart
street which was
also in Bedford Stuyvesant.
And not far from over
there. So I guess that's where people know
after the lower side.
What.
Yes
Yes We bought a house on president.
No
now
we bought that house and signed the contract in nineteen sixty eight.
It took us till nine hundred seventy to get into what we were buying
from crazy
lady.
But there were a lot of crazy ladies around here in those times who told
us the building was decontrol them we came to took
the contract
signing and she had no decontrol papers
sold then it turned out she had the right to get get a
decontrol but she hadn't done it.
OK because she had done the conversion from one family into apartments.
So we had to wait till she got the control papers in order to close.
Seven
years
and then my husband I
separated. And I'm he was some presence on the
park blocked. I moved to
cancel between seventh and eighth. And I live about
three years and then for my half of the present and I bought
a house on Fourth Street between Fifth and Sixth which I've been in
from thirty
years and my
daughter grew up in this neighborhood she went to public school.
She went to three twenty she went to high as eighty eight
which want to know if I knew better.
I probably was a centrist. School
years and then she went to middle
and. You know she's grown to
be an age a cave
person and I can't possibly I'm just name why
she didn't want to
live she lives in central Connecticut.
She wanted she didn't want to live
in the city she had an experience.
When she was in college but she lived
in and she and she came
back here and she had summer
job working
for
department something or social work social
welfare and aid so
prices and she was like in
the put us are and people were
hassling young
kids so. She said
how could you live
here.
Well I can't tell you about all of what I like about Brooklyn stitch defer
shipping. I think I
like that the best. I like the high density of people. I
like the fact that it had an ambulatory
life when I was first with was
done Long Island for a year and a
half and you had to get in the car to get
a bottle of milk or to mail a
letter and here. What I
said if I'm wrong on Seventh
Avenue the ocean no way I won't.
No You know when in the early years
here. You know we were connected in many
ways
is a babysitting
co-op individual food co-op not
the big one the time you're in huge tree. We go to the Brooklyn
Terminal Market to get fruits and vegetables and Jerry Parr to bring them
back and divide them up and everybody took a share. But there
was many community organizations and that's how we measure for
them and and the babysitting
pool was great.
You got when you joined thirty tickets each ticket was a half hour.
So if someone sat for you you gave them two tickets an
hour and if you sat for memes you'd get them
back and you know when you call
the people you like to a kid your age if your kid and
it was a great
thing was very very nice. Oh and the most
important thing. It was a
time of consciousness raising groups. You know
what they all are. And
so. Most
of the people I knew here or consciousness raising
groups they started at different times with
different scientists
and we had one that
was kind of diverse because somehow.
We hope in with now and they sent us people
from out of the neighborhood who were.
You know slightly different
backgrounds. I mean we had an ex not him or her.
And we had African-American young women
who had a very different background from
all you
know it was great it changed all
of our
lives.
And my dearest
friends come from that time I live.
No question
that because the world watched us
by a lot of this and that
but we really became in to really knew each
other that.
It was a basis for great friendships
that have lasted that
C.R. and seventy one seventy
two
and I was going to buy plants from the book and
turn on the market with two people I knew from the babysitting pool and they
told me they got it they were going to this meeting.
This is why don't you come. I didn't know what it was one one.
None of us you know we just played a year.
And
people went through a lot of changes and changes in
their expectations of still
lives.
I think it
was very much for the better.
Well
we're just OK.
I like like
say that from the time I was a trial.
The Brooklyn
public library has a very important to me.
As I
said my fish delish nine years
old and she took me
to Cal bridge to get my first
library card I should have said.
And I just
remember how because I knew
how to write my name.
But you couldn't write it in pencil you had to write
it in pain that you dipped in a bottle of
ink and I was terrified I was going to blot out or
make a big mess. And I just love wide
prairie and you know I have from a lot of memories.
All of the same
building and mostly for myself as a little
child Chandra was where I went with my sister who was by then
in college or something but my library was the one
on Dekalb brochure that was renovated probably ten years
ago although the May Come. Was closer to us
we never went
there I don't
know
I used to go to the also Brooklyn Children's Museum wonder in the old hang
out it was a little walled town kind
of I wouldn't exactly call it the mansion.
I used to go there and my daughter was to Brooklyn. They're
called Children's you see. Current
incarnation. So.
If you get me go out if. I
don't think.
I really wanted to do
it I mean I'm interested in neighborhood
history
and I'm trying to get
together this summer when
I'm when things are quiet. I'm going to go on Ancestry
dot and find out. I
know how my mother
came to this country to find my father came and.
Her year and a half year
all and can't
find my fish just thought she had the bug she came out but.
We both share the bills leading up to Boulder
and they don't
have a record of them.
So I'd like to try to do some of
that.